welcome to beyond corp in a bottle where
we explore journeys into the world of
context to where access and zero trust
networks more and more companies have
shifted to bring your own device
policies allowing employees to work with
the computers they know and love this
also reduces the IT spend per employee a
popular if troublesome trend but as we
think about securing corporate services
and applications we need to ask how
healthy are those devices should I trust
them with my company's data no no you
should not because you don't know what's
on them you don't know anything about
them let's look at how our friends at
Slager Bank and Trust tackle this
problem using endpoint verification and
access context manager on GCP first
gather the data they use the Google
admin controls to install the endpoint
verification Chrome extension on all
devices under active management they
also told employees using your own
laptops to install the same extension
next they turn to GCPs
access context manager to create rules
and policies around trust they could
define their own rules for earning
enough trust to get to internal
applications to start out they made
rules based on minimum Chrome OS version
now in nobody with an out-of-date
Chromebook would be able to access their
company data as they gather more device
information they added rules based on
other factors to make sure nobody with
an unencrypted disk could leak
information through a loss device and
then they settled on access policy that
looked like this a low trust tier for
up-to-date device and a higher trust
tier for encrypted and up-to-date
devices when someone signs in who
doesn't meet the security criteria
they'll see this instead this step
allowed the teams is Slager to improve
their control over secure access to the
company systems while still preserving
bring your own device policies to get
more detail check out my post linked
below for step-by-step instructions and
subscribe for more videos on
context-aware access when it comes to
protecting your company keep your data
yours
[Music]